amanece en la frontera entre ucrania y
polonia familias enteras se movilizaron
durante toda la noche buscan refugio de
la ofensiva militar rusa
algunos no han podido salir y se
encuentran atrapados en ucrania es el
caso de la familia de ole nabo busca
quien lleva horas esperando a su esposo
e hijo en el cruce fronterizo de medica
tengo un niño del otro lado es
incomprensible no sé cómo puedo
recuperar al niño no tengo pasaporte
sólo tengo una identificación polaca y
no puedo pasar la frontera no sé qué
hacer los familiares yolena son algunos
de los tantos ciudadanos que huyen de
diversas partes del país vecino
venimos de kharkiv ahí es donde teníamos
apartamentos
nos fuimos hace dos semanas nos mudamos
a leópolis porque había menos peligro
pero también nos fuimos de leópolis en
medio de la difícil situación la
solidaridad se hace presente y van dos
propietario de una empresa de transporte
en la ciudad polaca de cracovia ha
puesto a disposición toda su flota para
movilizar a los desplazados
vine aquí para ayudar a la gente de
ucrania gratis tengo 8 autos y todos
están aquí quiero sacar a la gente de
esta guerra y traerlos a cracovia
polonia ha flexibilizado sus
restricciones en los cruces fronterizos
y eliminó los requisitos en torno al cob
y 19 se estima que aproximadamente
100.000 ciudadanos están en estos
momentos huyendo del conflicto